it's fantastic to see you here at
collector mania today have you been
enjoying it
I've had a really lovely day it's been
fantastic and I actually love this venue
so I'm sitting there looking outside and
I mean I'm it Lewis teaming with Ryan
but I mean it's still outside and it's
lovely and there's green and it's great
as opposed to gray having a wall yeah
very fresh today keeps us all alive and
I tell you there's bright eyes sparkling
away freezing cold but fantastic now of
course we've seen you this season in
Game of Thrones in the first episode
tell us a little bit about filming that
scene well I tell you the main thing
about it was actually going to the
location and the location because it was
up on the Antrim coast and we got up
very early in the morning obviously to
get there and driving along the coast
road with the Sun rising over the RSC
and Scotland appearing in the distance
absolutely stunning and then those
beautiful location up on the cliffs and
then the lunch break we were you know
just sitting there eating lunch
looking out across to the mall of cantar
and Ailsa Craig and all that was just
gorgeous and the sea was blue it was
absolutely stunning and a rather fun
scene to film as well so it was a good
day yeah are you working with Ada and
Gillan on that one and sophie turner
weren't you as I've only worked with
Aiden Gillen unsafety Turner very nice
no no great fun great and I'm big
admirer of both of them yeah
I made and does some fascinating works
here in Ireland
what's it like coming into such a big
show that's got so many fans it's so
high just Game of Thrones everyone seems
to be constantly talking about that has
all these millions it feels like
sometimes characters and different
machination x' and plot lines and
subplots going on and then you've got to
come in as this character who has a few
scenes how do you kind of feel yourself
insert yourself in them well you know
it's like any job you get sent the
script you you see what you're doing and
you go and do it and sometimes you're on
a great big blockbuster movie with Meryl
Streep sometimes you're on you know
something for e4 with a bunch of young
guys you've never heard of but who your
children absolutely know everything
about and so coming onto Game of Thrones
I was very aware what a huge series this
was it was the only thing my daughters
were impressed that I was in ever and
I've been acting for well over thirty
years and and also when you actually go
on the set in Belfast in particular
those huge sets you realize that you're
on a very serious production and it's
fantastic but as an actor you just get
on with it you just do it do you think
will see your character again because I
mean obviously they've moved on from the
vowel now but things come around go
right again I have no idea I am
apparently on it again I've been booked
for a couple more and I have no idea
what I'm doing for all I know I'm gonna
have my head chopped off or I just don't
know and because I haven't actually read
the books what happens
Lord Yen rice or Yan rice so you
mentioned you've contracted for two more
episodes for Game of Thrones are we
looking forward to seeing you in season
six then I assume adieu season six cuz
last one we film season five therefore
it has to be season six yeah I have no
idea what I'm doing I'm told I wanted in
July and then I wanted in December so
I've no idea what that means
but I just can't wait to see what
not for me no fantastic two different
times of years so you could be very hot
in July very cold and very very hot in
July and in the amount of kitai we're on
that show I mean the last the first
scene I filmed there Belfast was the
hottest place in the United Kingdom that
day and I had so much stuff on I can't
tell you I lost about a stone doing that
one and then of course doing of the
county antrim one yeah major sunburn
because we're out all day December could
be very different yeah but they were
like Game of Thrones could have their
Game of Thrones diet you know with all
the clothes you weren't filming in July
fantastic no just do lots of that suits
man you could get the chop we don't know
if if you did get the chop in Game of
Thrones how do you like to go cuz it's
been some very traumatic death and all
sorts of gruesome and terrible ways in
battle on horseback obviously yes
possibly with an arrow in the eye you
know something like that I know it's
been done before but you know oh I think
so yes I don't want to go in my bath or
something like that be boring yeah just
fall over yeah Ahri's dead move on yeah
I do get killed quite a lot though I've
been shocked and I've had a 5-iron
bearing in my skull ya know I guess
favorite death of you that you had on
screen so far I think I should on
favorite was summer murders 5-iron in
the head in a word with my youngest
daughter watching and calling action
which was fantastic she thought it was
fantastic me lying there on the forest
floor blood spilling out of my head
loved it totally unbothered by there
so she would look forward to a great
death for you on Game of Thrones and if
she's a fan of that she'd love to see
some pretty bloody and gruesome now now
do her obviously you only had a little
bit of interaction on the show with
little fingers character Aiden Gillan's
character little finger but what did you
make of him when you kind of were
dealing with him Littlefinger nya yeah
it's quite interesting because I don't
quite know yet what to making because I
actually haven't had enough to do them
and I'm sort of thinking are you a
ghastly little like really evil oh just
a smooth operator I don't know enough
about it
so I am actually quite wary of him you
know I don't quite know how to play it I
don't know whether that's right for my
character but I have a suspicion it
might be I don't know what little
fingers wide up to when you get the
scripts do your part do you get kind of
a certain amount of input from the
director and maybe the other actors who
are you kind of have more of a larger
part in the show and therefore know the
arc and stuff like that
none at all show up say the lines and I
if I get them right
I assume that'll be fine and we'll move
on if I get them wrong I assume I'll be
be told to do them again
sometimes I sort of I think sometimes I
try to go a bit more comedic than they
actually want me to so I was told to cut
out the comedy on once
I cut it on it do what I'm told
so no I mean no the impetus is whatever
you need to have but the scenes are
usually fairly clear so it's not
shouldn't be too much of a problem tell
me a little bit about what other people
have been asking you today about your
various roles you've had over the years
but of course as you said you've been
working for a number of years now in
many different roles having new
yeah I feel lovely I'm main thing here
has been Game of Thrones obviously
that's the biggest thing that's very
interesting actually because I've only
just come into Game of Thrones and it
does change things you know that really
kicks things up because it has such a
huge viewing audience Doctor Who of
course I was in the bring back series
with Christopher Eccleston which was
very very exciting to be in that was
great fun that was lovely a little bit
of Braveheart and a lot of people coming
off that heartbeat which was a TV series
I was in for 18 years but of course this
isn't exactly a heart big conventions
and Doctor Who I mean what was I
thinking that was you know the new
beginning as it were doctor who wasn't
it how exciting was it to be part of
that was something you knew you liked to
the kid or oh yeah no as a kid I mean I
was watching in the sixties from behind
the sofa like everyone else and I always
thought I was absolutely fantastic
and then then it went through so many
different iterations that you know I
lost track of it and then it disappeared
altogether and then suddenly we heard it
was coming back with Chris Eccleston who
I think is a fabulous actor and I got
asked into audition and got the part and
was I was absolutely thrilled because it
was to bring back serious it was you
know there was a huge amount of buzz
about it and so it's very sad to be in a
double episode tear which was fantastic
and it was a fun episode as well what
was it like being part on playing the
part on that set being there for the
first time well you were aware that it
was it was new in a strange way although
we all knew what we were doing we also
none of us did quite know what we were
doing we probably didn't quite know what
we had and how it was going to end up
you know we knew what we felt it was
like but you never quite know what it's
gonna be like when it's finally put
together so you're always slightly
working in the dark but you know we did
it and out it came and they're still
making it
you know so something obviously worked
do you think about the latest dr. Peter
Capaldi well I have I wrote a piece yes
I think I have and again another top
top-flight actor I'm not seeing this
table here I haven't watched doctoring
myself
since about 1968 so but I know Peter is
absolutely I mean I think a superb
choice got all that character and such
an intelligent actor you know brilliant
really
he worked of course with Christopher
Eccleston you said you thought was
growing out in two years I mean what did
you think when he decided to step away
from the wrong well I wasn't so
surprised because that's Christopher all
over you know he does it and then he
moves on he's an actor of enormous
integrity and I think he just felt
fantastic ten episodes like it was time
to go on you know that's what he does
I'm good fan good and what could we look
forward to saying for you next well I
don't know notes Game of Thrones
absolutely a little bit on e4 comedy
thing which is very far the brand is a
daytime TV thing which I've just
finished filming one of those detective
mystery rather farm 7-9 50s in the
Cotswolds so you go and wander around
the Cotswolds filming fantastic and I
think of Versailles which is coming outs
about the building of Versailles which
looks quite interesting it's a big
french-canadian Anglo production so I
don't know when that's coming out but I
did that earlier this year in lovely
talking to you Rufus thanks Emmett to
your time today and enjoy the rest of
your day thank you very much lovely
you